desire just means there's something the
character wants it isn't necessarily
confined to sexual or romantic desire
that just happens to be in those two
movies there were there was this sort of
illicit sexual I don't know if it was
really illicit in nine weeks or how
you'd categorize it but the desire could
well on a visible level the desire could
be to win a competition in fact if you
look at at Hollywood movies probably 90%
of Hollywood movies are about characters
who all want to do one of basically
three or four things and that is they
either want to win a competition or win
the love of another character so that
encompasses all sports movies and all
romantic comedies and love stories or or
romantic - at movies or they want to
stop like stop something bad from
happening that's all horror movies most
science fiction movies all thrillers all
murder mysteries although Hollywood
really doesn't do murder mysteries so
much but that's about stopping a killer
from getting away with the murder or
they want to escape from some bad
situation like Great Escape or panic
room or hunt for the wildering they want
to go get something of value and own it
possess it at the end of the story so
that's all heist movies it's kidnapping
stories rescue stories we've got to go
get this person and get them to safety
and if you look at the top box-office
movies for any given year I bet probably
90 out of 100 are gonna fall into one of
those four categories of goal okay so
desire doesn't necessarily mean romantic
interest it could be conquering you know
in in the case of the Helen Mirren movie
that you mentioned earlier wanting to
find the terrorists that conquer is is
the desire that moves it through but the
conflict is trying to find these
terrorists who have moved throughout the
area yeah that's part of the conflict
her goal that's a stop movie she wants
to stop the terrorists from leaving the
house where they can take because there
discover that their their suicide
bombers or their arming some suicide
bombers so they're going to go into some
populous place and kill a lot of people
and they want she wants to stop them
part of the conflict is they've got to
find them they've got to make sure it's
them they've got to get the drone in
position but part of the conflict is
what happens when an innocent bystander
comes into the the the field where the
chloral collateral damage is going to be
done if there's an innocent person there
it starts a moral dilemma of is one
person's life worth risking the lives of
a hundred to save so then there could
become this moral conflict - but they're
all obstacles to her doing what she
wants which is stop the terrorists
you